bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver dans le set fit loisirs vos
idées sorties dans le département on
commence tout de suite avec le sommaire
de ce numéro du 2 au 4 mars versailles
vibrera au rythme du son électro de
nombreux concerts sont organisés pour
cette première édition d' électro chic
festival versailles touch nous recevront
en plateau
ludovic moreau secrétaire général de
l'événement et en parlera peintures et
sculptures à voisins le bretonneux des
oeuvres qui revisite l'histoire de l'art
ou qui s'interroge sur les tensions du
corps reportage à suivre traite appel à
votre âme d'artiste le centre alfred de
vigny lance un concours d'arts
plastiques aucune limite si ce n'est
votre créativité
les détails avec mélanie ok mais on
commence par de la musique de coeur
trois concerts ont lieu ce soir et
dimanche à l'église sainte élisabeth de
versailles et l'église notre dame de la
résurrection du chesnay un festival au
profit de la ville d'hama tritsch et en
italie détruite par les tremblements de
terre le répertoire chanté ira du
classique avec verdi au rock des beatles
on écoute un mot de l'organisatrice
matin zerbo cette ville c'est lé symbole
de tous les temps brement de terre qui
sont arrivés l'année dernière et
l'italie c'est un geste le nôtre bien
sûr on espère d'avoir une grande
participation du public pour accueillir
la somme la plus importante pour pour à
madrid chez mais c'est un geste de
solidarité
on se sent proche de gens qui ont tout
perdu
versailles toujours mais du côté des
musiques électroniques cette fois vous
connaissez forcément air ou daft punk
originaire de versailles ils ont marqué
les années 90 et aujourd'hui la relève
est assurée de nouveaux artistes suivent
le même mouvement un festival leur est
même consacré avec nous ludovic moreau
secrétaire général de l'omd de vélizy
qui participent au festival électro chic
bonjour bonjour alors on le rappelle
c'est la première édition de ce festival
la plupart des concerts auront lieu chez
vous à londres
qu'est ce qui a motivé la création d'
électro chic mais le fait que ce soit le
berceau de l'électronique qui se trouve
à versailles et vélizy d'enquêté juste à
côté touche versailles et donc c'est
suite à une rencontre entre le directeur
de l'undd et le directeur des affaires
culturelles de versailles qui sont
passionnés d'électro que voilà un an ils
ont eu l'idée de faire un festival
autour de la french touch si on veut qui
vient de versailles cette fameuse
versailles touch des artistes parisiens
versaillais ont contribué à l'essor de
ce courant musical
il y aura trois dates enfin trois
grosses dates trois soirées concerts
avec des artistes de versailles
notamment il a commence jeudi prochain
ouais tout à fait donc avec une soirée
100% versailles le jeudi 2 avec
notamment encore turzi et saint michel
qui sont voilà des produits de
versailles et ensuite donc le deuxième
jour on découvrait juarez qui est une
création spéciale pour l'événement
thylacine aussi qu est un jeune artiste
très prometteur et danger' et le
troisième soir il y aura agar agar
caspian foule d'abord agar agar une
jeune jeune équipe
voilà plus très prometteuse et ensuite
qu asus qui est vraiment la figure une
des figures de la french town dix années
90 2000
un beau programme du coin prévisions on
va juste revenir sur la première date
qui a lieu jeudi prochain vous l'avais
dit dans les groupes il y aura 100
michel un groupe composé de jeunes
versailles et ils pratiquent un style
électro pop pardon et je vous propose
d'écouter justement un extrait on se
retrouve après
[Musique]
c
m
[Musique]
ces crimes
ce que
[Musique]
il y aura une petite exclusivité sur ce
concert justement avec saint michel où
est tout à fait parce que don qu'ils ont
quelques années d'existence maintenant
ils sont en pleine préparation de leur
nouvel album est donc à londres
spécialement ils vont nous présenter une
première mouture en fait du spectacle du
7 qui vont tourner ensuite et on l'a
entendu justement sur la scène actuelle
est très très influencée en fait à part
les grands noms air daft punk comment la
cité tout à l'heure on retrouve cette
même sensibilité artistique chez les
jeunes groupes chez les nouveau groupe
bel a comme on a pu l'entendre voilà il
ya une sorte d'héritage en fait de ces
artistes
r ça c'est sûr qu asus phoenix aussi un
groupe qui voilà qui est connu aussi
internationalement et donc il ya ceux il
ya ce côté pop aussi ce côté chanter il
ya l'électro qui est très présent si
kavinsky aussi ou ou sébastien tellier
par exemple donc on sent cette mouvance
et héritage d'une génération à une autre
et durant le festival il n'y a pas que
les concerts il ya d'autres événements
qui eux se poursuivre jusqu'au 18 mars
également oui ça se casse qui s'appelle
le choc du chic
donc c'est à l'initiative de la ville de
vélizy villacoublay
l'espace jeunesse la médiathèque l'école
de musique et de danse aussi qu'ils
aient eu envie justement de profiter de
cet événement est de proposer des
ateliers des rencontres autour de cette
culture qui est pas si connu que ça et
puis de faire une grande soirée de
clôture avait dit si donc il y en a pour
tous les goûts même si on n'a pas
forcément envie d'assister au concert et
les ateliers sont rentrés entrée libre
tout reste à faire même on imagine qu'il
ya beaucoup de demandes oui ça part bien
il ya des ateliers aussi à versailles
alors pendant aussi le festival
mais il ya des choses aussi dans le
cadre du festival du choc du chic
alors qu'est ce qui fait de versa
justement un vivier de la musique
électronique
et bien c'est toute une génération donc
notamment les daft punk est qui qui sont
célèbres dans le monde entier
ben certain sens du rythme
d
beaucoup de musique par ordinateur
quelque chose qui était pas si courant à
l'époque de jeunes gens voilà qui
étaient dans un bus dans un bain musical
culturel esthétique et qui se sont un
peu rencontrer c'est un peu une
génération
des graphistes et des des musiciens
voilà qui ensuite ont fait connaître la
france dans le monde entier pense à ce
courant c'est un style roman moderne
c'est un style d'aujourd'hui encore très
contemporain très présent oui pour ça
qu'ils aient un esprit c'est ce qui nous
intéresse dans ce steve à il ya cette
génération de pionniers et puis il ya
les enfants c'est vraiment un berceau de
la culture french-touch très bien ma
merci en tout cas lui donne siamouroux
d'être venu sur notre plateau alors on
le rappelle le festival électro chic
commence jeudi prochain les concerts
commencent jeudi prochain et toutes les
dates des ateliers également sont à
retrouver sur le site internet et la
maison de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux accueille
actuellement une exposition peintures et
sculptures
les travaux de jocelyne brise l'est
revisite l'histoire de l'art et répondre
aux cultures primitives des vagues
godsick découvertes sur les images de
nicolas kirillovitch c'est un déjeuner
sur l'herbe revisité en inversant les
rôles de l'oeuvre de manet ce tableau
met en scène un homme nu entouré de
femmes habillées reprendre l'histoire de
l'art avec humour jocelyne brise l'est
en a fait sa spécialité
j'ai repris donc des velasquez des
monnaies des manèges
ingres j'essaye de faire parfois de
l'ironie et j'accompagne donc cette
référence ça peut être un comment dire
un extrait de l'oeuvre pas forcément
l'oeuvre en entier et je la compagne
avec une peinture que qui est peut-être
plus contemporaine il assure que celle
de l'époque une quarantaine de ses
toiles ont investi l'espace de covile
elles dialoguent avec les sculptures des
vagues hautes sic et sa recherche sur l'
équilibre
j'aime bien les tensions qui peut se
montrer dans cette position-là la
sculpteuse je peux la positionner
différentes manières c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de
particulièrement frontalité il n'y a pas
de face il n'y a pas de côté on peut
regarder on peut prendre la nana est
regardée de tous les côtés et on peut la
pause et aussi dans différentes manières
elle va être aussi bien comme ça ou
comme ça
les deux artistes amis depuis 20 ans ont
monté cette exposition ensemble une
discussion entre primitif et
contemporain à découvrir jusqu'au 5 mars
exposition encore les amazones de la
révolution joue les prolongations
jusqu'au 5 mars
elle met en lumière le rapport entre les
femmes et la violence des événements
révolutionnaires un aspect moins connu
notre histoire
l'exposition leur rendons justice elle
est toujours à découvrir au musée
lambinet on écoute un mot de martial
poirson le commissaire il était passé
sur notre antenne
ces femmes ces fameuses amazones de la
mission française auquel le livre en
justice les femmes qui ont revendiqué
une égalité de traitement avec les
hommes dix ans si on nation que monter à
la guillotine on doit pouvoir monter
également à la tribune et qui revendique
notamment c'est le cas de théroigne de
méricourt en particulier l'utilisation
de la violence comme un outil politique
pour l'histoire
et pour ce rendez-vous juniors on va
faire appel à vos talents d'artiste un
concours est actuellement proposée
bonjour mais la lie bonjour avec camille
alors c'est le centre alfred de vigny de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui lance le défi
il s'adresse à tous les vices ynwa bien
sûr mais les saint quentinois
il n'y a pas de limite d'âge les adultes
peuvent y participer mais aussi les
enfants puisque les écoles de voisins
ont été sollicités pour le thème rien de
plus simple tout est dans le titre
si alfred de vigny je laisse judy bio la
coordinatrice du centre nous en dire un
peu plus on s'est dit si alfred de vigny
voilà était là qu'est ce qu'ils
aimeraient voir qu'est-ce qu'il est à
quai on a choisi une phrase donc on peut
la voir ici et je vois au delà quatre
formes légères qui dansaient sous la
lune au milieu des bruyères
on sait on a beaucoup réfléchi sur la
phrase qu'on avait choisir fallait
qu'elle soit quand même assez imagée et
qu'on puisse retrouver différents
éléments pour construire quelque chose
autour de ça alfredo ministre était un
auteur il a écrit des romans des essais
des textes des poèmes
voilà et ça s'est tirée d'un texte qui
s'appelle le loup est donc hormis la
thématique qu'il faut respecter on peut
tout faire tout faire ou presque parce
qu'il ya quand même quelques consignes
qui sont données principalement autour
des techniques en fait alors il ya de la
vidéo de la photo du texte du dessin de
la peinture de la sculpture du modelage
ou encore de la couture largement de
qualys laisser libre cours à son
imagination et julie me confiait que des
participants sont déjà venus au centre
pour débuter leur création certains font
de la photographie et du body painting
mais qui dit concours dit sélection il
récompense bien sûr tout à fait la
première étape ce sera une exposition en
mai pendant deux ou trois semaines au
sein même de la galerie du centre plus
de 40 oeuvres peuvent être exposées et
s'il ya beaucoup trop de propositions
une sélection sera faite avec parfois
peut-être déroulement c'est les équipes
du centre qui feront la sélection et il
y aura aussi un prix du public avec un
lot qui est en train de se construire
écouter on a demandé à beaucoup de
musées de nous envoyer les places par
exemple
on a demandé à pompidou beaucoup de
musées parisiens parce qu'on s'est dit
que c'était un cadeau intéressant pour
des artistes que d'aller visiter des
musées
alors pour participer rien de plus
simple direction le site internet du
centre et s'affiche en bas de l'écran
vous pouvez récupérer votre bulletin
d'inscription et le règlement du
concours
vous avez jusqu'au 1er mai pour déposer
le bulletin d'inscription
elle est gratuite les oeuvres elles
devront être déposés du 1er au 6 mai et
la famille le reste plus qu'à laisser
libre cours à l'imagination
merci beaucoup mélanine de nous avoir
parlé de ce concours alors si vous vous
sentez l'âme artistique il ne vous reste
plus qu'à dégainer pinceaux crayons ou
au choix appareil photo merci beaucoup
et on passe maintenant à notre agenda
avec un rendez vous à noter deux
gymnases des droits de l'homme de
guyancourt une compétition phase finale
1re et 2e divisions minines effet eu
ouïe minimes pardon et féminine ce sera
jusqu'à 21h30 samedi et jusqu'à 18
heures dimanche et avant de se quitter
n'oubliez pas que mardi c'est mardi gras
alors sortez vos plus beaux costumes
en attendant je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end et une très bonne
soirée
[Musique]